This house printed in 3D is made with waste from
the forestry industry and it is 1st worldwide.
Developed in the United States by the University of Mayen,
this innovation makes it possible to build 1 house from locally produced
biosourced materials such as wood cure or 1 corn-based lion The wooden
house was printed in 3D using an industrial polymer printer.
In the house,
there is a living room,
a kitchen,
a work space and a bedroom.
The house is completely renovated and highly insulated
thanks to 100% wooden insulation.
This 3D printing technique with locally sourced materials makes it possible to
obtain more responsible and cheaper housing and thus allow low-income families
to find housing more easily to follow other world-changing projects.
It happens here.